what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so getting into Nightwing rebirth it's
actually been a while since we covered
anything Nightwing related other reason
why is because of the fact that remember
when it comes to Nightwing zone solo
series for the most part he's just kind
of out there in left field dealing with
things on his own and it's kind of
interesting is because there really is
no supporting cast here I mean there's
Shaun sang insofar as you know her
basically being his love interest but
that's really about it
for the most part when it comes to DC
Comics when we think of like Batman for
example Batman's got Duke you know in
his own stories and if he didn't there'd
be some other iteration of Robin that
exists out there somewhere types of
comics you tease up with other members
of that family when it comes to action
comics you see Superman alongside other
superheroes when it comes to the main
Superman story I usually see him dealing
with like Lois Lane or a son Jonathan or
something along those lines
Nightwing is very much out there by
himself and the reason for this is
because of the fact that with Nightwing
if you're new to DC Comics he's
currently on the Titans team and so that
really gives us the ability to see him
cross over with other superheroes in a
way to creates more of a full and richer
story but again the idea here with the
Nightwing rebirth line of stories if
you're just joining us or if you that's
coming across this video is a DC has
just now gone down the road of sending
Nightwing back to blüdhaven and the
reason why this matters is because
before the new 52 blüdhaven was
Nightwing zone Gotham City that's really
what it was way back when Dick Grayson
first appeared he was that man's
sidekick for decades eventually he was
rolled over into becoming his own
superhero called Nightwing and then the
next step was to basically give him his
own city to protect and so going into
the new 52
Nightwing was the guardian of blood
Haven now the issue was that when the
new 52 launched DC revamped him
completely and the result was that he
was no longer the protector of blood
Haven he was just like the spy working
for an organization called spiral but
the idea of sitting him like back to
blüdhaven is designed for the purpose of
creating a measure of familiarity with
existing DC fans who were reading before
the new 52 reboot but it's also designed
to do is give you guys something fresh
if you're just now joining in or
something along those lines now the
other half of this is that blüdhaven is
really viewed in a lot of ways as more
hopeless than gotham city and that's
kind of a crazy thing going pound for
pound I would say that Bludhaven it's
about on par with Gotham City it doesn't
have the same
kind of criminal element instead what it
really just has is like corruption a
governmental corruption police
corruption different things like that
Gotham is known for the Riddler the
Joker two-faced penguin you know those
guys but with the idea of Bludhaven as
it exists now Nightwing's trying to
clean up the city insofar as he's trying
to fight against government and police
corruption as he is trying to deal with
small-time crooks and it was always that
way Knight we never really had his own
version of the Joker or anything along
those lines it was always just dealing
with trying to make sure that blüdhaven
didn't completely go to pot now the
other half of this is that as he's doing
his nightly patrol he basically comes
across a woman who's being accosted by a
guy for me whenever I read these comics
I always imagine things going down
differently for example Knightley was
the one guy they can like tear everybody
up he's the one guy who's not down and
draaby and you know oh man things are
just really bad he's not that guy he's
the guy who's just like hey the glass is
half-full and it's always kind of cool
and refreshing it's one of the things
that always made him so vibrant the
issue with this is that with this woman
being accosted and Nightwing basically
stopping the perpetrator the woman grabs
the perpetrators gun and goes to shoot
him now of course this results in Wally
West the classic flash stepping in to
stop him now something to keep in mind
about this and something to bear when it
comes to this particular story is that
really Nightwing and Wally West are a
couple of characters who basically know
everything that's going on now Wally
West seems to know a little bit more but
dick Grayson's basically then woken up
to what's going on keep in mind the way
the whole DC rebirth and you know the
new 52 worked in tandem is that the new
52 was a reboot who is basically hey
here's all these new characters DC
rebirth came back and said no no things
were supposed to be the way they were
before the new 52 but someone changed
something now classic Wally West was the
guy who was just out there he was the
missing link he was the guy who came
along and said I don't know what's going
on here but your memories had been
modified the idea is that whit classic
Wally West he's really pulling double
duty in terms of his life as a superhero
and his personal life remember you know
his love interest was Linda that was the
whole great big huge thing before the
new 52 the idea of DC rebirth is to
bring her back but to basically do it in
a way where they can more or less
rekindled their relationship and that's
really what classic Wally West talks
about here his biggest issue is that he
seems like he's bearing the weight of
the world on his shoulders but the idea
is that this story actually kind of has
a coming together of
to Wally West Lee sits down and
says everything is just a little too
much for me to take on at the moment I
mean I have people that I can confide
and I can talk to Barry Allen
but he's always off doing his own thing
I can't really go talk to Linda because
who she is now is not who she was before
it's not the Linda that I remember and
so the cool thing about this is that
what they end up doing is actually
taking off to a dive bar and then
they're met by a couple of chicks now I
don't know what these guys are thinking
I would have been like yeah let's go
back to like your place or my place or
something but like we're going to work
out some stress and that's why things
like this are so important in truth this
was never really an aspect of comic
books that existed for any measure of
time really before the 1970s comic books
were just superhero saving the day
that's really what it was for the most
part it's just these small little
moments but the funny thing about this
is that once they make their way outside
people's belongings start vanishing and
this is cool because what this story
begins to do is kind of turn into like a
1960s feel with regards to these two
superheroes and the reason why I say
that is again the era of like more
dynamic powers the era of more
character-driven powers didn't really
emerge until like the 60s 70s 80s 90s
that kind of a thing and so what is up
happening here at least what they seem
to be gathering is that people's
belongings are just kind of banishing up
in thin air so we don't know if
somebody's teleporting them out we have
no idea what the case may be but the
one-liners that come out of here you
know the little zingers different things
like that the references to these old
school stories names like this skipper
things along those lines
that's all going back to the old school
age of superheroes Nightwing in the
flash versus the skipper in the case of
the vanishing valuables that's a title
that you would have seen in like 1961
these are all just like references to
these old school comics and again that's
the nature of DC rebirth the nature of
DC rebirth is to kind of fulfill a bit
of nostalgia for an era of comics that
people never grew up in most people who
are reading comics right now weren't
reading them in the 1960s this wasn't
really a part of their repertoire but
the idea you know really from from Geoff
Johns a guy who's spearheading DC
rebirth the very nature of characters
back then was that there was no moral
ambiguity there was a good guy there was
a bad guy the superhero stopped the bad
guy the day was saved the comic was over
that's basically how those stories
function so again this is kind of a
throwback to that and the reason why is
because we just end up finding out of
the person who's committing these crimes
is just a guy who has the ability to
manipulate time now it's not in
Aaron power that he has it's not
something that he was simply just given
or born with whatever the case may be
it's actually a piece of off world
technology that allows him to achieve
this but it's cool because what this
does is it really gives us a glimpse of
what it looks like when a person
manipulates time within the comic itself
if I were to sit you down and I were to
show you a person who could teleport and
show you a person who can manipulate
time in terms of how your visible eye
sees it there's no difference all you
know is that they were there and now
they're there whether it's because they
stopped time and then walked over there
whether it's because they just
teleported there while you were going to
attack them it's irrelevant the idea
here is that they are basically
untouchable and that's the cool thing
about this is because this is designed
to take something that's relatively
small the idea of manipulating time give
it to a small time guy and then see what
he can do with it now the reason why I
say this is so interesting is because
when it comes to manipulating time in
comic books most fans absolutely hate it
because time travel is used by writer to
write themselves out of a hole that they
dug you know they have this amazing
story and they can't figure out exactly
what to do you know and they're like
well I mean how do we end this well just
time-travel Matthew Molloy and Marvel
Comics is a perfect example this mutant
that's godly powerful and writer Brian
Michael Bendis didn't know how to end
the story so we just had them go back in
time and prevent Matthew Malloy from
ever being born it's an extremely lazy
way to end a story that's one of the
things that fans would become accustomed
to one time travel is invoked and this
it's not that way it's just a small-time
guy who figured if I can manipulate time
I'm just going to freeze it steal
people's stuff and then call it a day
and it's actually pretty smart
it's actually pretty cool to see
somebody using time manipulation in that
fashion
not only that what just does is it takes
someone like classic Wally West and
makes him virtually powerless now
remember when it comes to the different
iterations of the flash one of the
things that DC has done over the years
in order to differentiate the various
forms of the flash it's to give them
different iterations of their powers or
to make one more powerful than the other
stealing speed from other people
time-traveling being able to jump from
the future to the past back to the
present you know being able to use all
these different abilities moving their
hands through physical objects so on and
so forth it's really cool to see these
kind of things unfold and that's what
happens with this classic Wally West is
by and large considered to have been the
most powerful version of the flash now
once Barry Allen came back after he was
basically resurrected during the
original flash rebirth story his power
basically bolstered and the idea was
that he's now the most powerful version
of the flash but the idea is that again
we're talking about beings who if BC had
a designation for Omega level they would
easily be Omega level characters and
they're just being stopped by a guy who
has the ability to freeze time but again
these scenarios require that the writing
be played out in a way that makes it
interesting and so what actually happens
here is Dick Grayson figures it out
if this guide lose calling himself time
bomb is basically able to control time
around people his technology is really
an extension of how well he is able to
focus meaning he can't manipulate time
in terms of controlling multiple people
and so what this does is it allows Dick
Grayson to basically put two and two
together if he stands where he is
classic wally west is going to die when
he gets hit by this train he's not
indestructible he's a normal human being
who can be shot in the head he's just
got the Speed Force to run really really
fast and a healing factor Dick Grayson
is like if I don't intervene Wally West
is going to die because Wally West is so
fast
he literally steps in pushes him out of
the sphere of influence and then in the
blink of an eye Wally West grabs him and
saves his life so it's a gamble but it's
cool to see it pay off and so again what
is up happening here is timebomb kind of
turns his attention away this momentary
distraction results in him basically
being defeated now here's a funny thing
about this time bomb character this is
not a villain that DC is just kind of
pulling out of thin air right time bomb
existed but to say that time bomb is
irrelevant is a overstatement if time
bomb is about as irrelevant as a person
could be he originally made his
appearance in Action Comics I want to
say it 661 and it was it was a team-up
story involving a Superman and Plastic
Man and it was really kind of cool
because it was like this made you know
really cool battle that took place
between them it was the idea that time
bomb as he existed then it basically
detonate any aspect of himself and then
restore so he was literally a walking
bomb and this instance this guy just
called him time bomb because he can
manipulate time but again you know it's
it's interesting it's a funny little
situation when it comes to these things
because it's small bits and pieces
basically being brought back into the
fray again but as the story begins to
wind down what we end up finding out is
that this time manipulation device
actually belonged to a villain named
Tigershark who I really don't know too
much about I need to do a little more
poking around about him but it belongs
to a villain named tiger
of course this guy basically having the
intention to bring down Bludhaven or
bring Ville a Bludhaven under his
control so again it's this continual
desire by DC to basically bolster the
roads of nightwing himself basically
throwing at us all these different
enemies that he's either faced in the
past or that are being created for the
first time and then in turn asking us
which one we like the most and then
keeping the ones that we seem to enjoy
the most so whenever you guys heard our
discussions where we talked about how
well you know DC Comics would come along
and it would test the waters with this
character and fans loved it so they kept
them around you're experiencing that in
real time right now characters who are
old school who are pre new 52 being
brought back to see whether or not
people are interested in that a few
small things these cool things that
really make for a cohesive story but if
you guys are new here to come this
explain to make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the Rob
cork you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]